for now though shireen let's get to it
the opt out window has closed
the decisions have been made 67
players you know i had someone tell me a
couple of weeks ago single digits will
be the number of opt-outs
67 the final tally and shireen if they
had more time
i have a feeling the number would have
been a lot higher
well and they wanted more time mike you
saw jamie collins quotes from yesterday
that he would have liked more time and
you know they want to see when they get
into practices how's it how it's going
to be the 11 11 stuff
i mean they've gotten a little taste of
it now and i get why the nfl wants the
window when they want it
because they don't want more guys to opt
out and frankly i'm kind of surprised
that more guys
didn't opt out and i know you have a
number of reasons from contracts
why they should have thought about
opting out but the window did close and
now it's
unusual circumstances is the only reason
they can opt out
now after the deadline yesterday
yeah if you are diagnosed with a new
health condition that puts you at higher
risk condition you didn't have before
thursday
august the 6th or if a family member is
hospitalized or dies from
covet 19. those are the two windows that
a player can opt out after
yesterday at 4 p.m eastern the other
thing to remember
and a lot of this is driven by
individual contract situations
specifically how much money would have
to be paid back potentially
in the event of a retirement but the
andrew luck route could be pursued
preseason retirement in-season
retirement on retirement you can
unretire all the way up until
late november we went through that with
jason witten two years ago and rob
gronkowski last year but there are
windows still there to walk away if
you're not comfortable and that's
shireen what ultimately should drive
this mark murphy the packers ceo who was
part of the negotiating team
said earlier this week we absolutely
wanted players to have the ability to
opt out we want them to not play if
they're not comfortable okay
fine why is the window so early and i've
seen people on twitter saying oh you've
had five months to decide no
you've had five days to decide you
haven't been in the building to feel how
safe you are or aren't
you haven't practiced 11 on 11 you
haven't been in a game
setting you haven't been in a locker
room before during or after a game
i'm hearing talk that they may
eventually it hasn't happened yet
but they may eventually take off those
tracking devices and leave them outside
the locker room
because once you go into the locker room
there's no way in hell they're going to
be able to keep the guys apart
and if one guy ends up positive they're
all going to be shut down because
they're all going to have a little green
light beeping
that shows they were in contact with
that guy so
you know circumstances are going to
change and
things are going to happen that haven't
happened yet and i just think it's only
fair if you care about these men as
human beings shireen to give them an
opportunity to revisit
their situation and ask themselves the
fair objective questions whether or not
they're still
comfortable yeah we saw that yesterday
with the dolphins mike that many of
their players they put six players on
the covet list as you first reported and
of those six it sounds like most or all
of them had contact with the player who
tested positive for covet not that they
tested positive for covid but that they
were around someone who did they got in
too close
contact so yeah we may see some of that
where they do take it off now there are
healthy fines if they do take it off
i am sure uh but but we may see some of
that but yeah they need longer to decide
we've seen it in baseball we've seen
players decide to opt out
in the middle of season we've seen
players decide to come back in the
middle of season i understand if the nfl
doesn't want those players to come back
but they should have more time to decide
to walk away
simply because we haven't seen them in
practices and other close
quarter situations i mean i don't think
they're having more than a few players
in the building at a time right now and
so once they get together as a group
things are going to change and they may
decide that this isn't for me
i want to walk away from this and as you
said retiring is probably the easiest
way now to do that but they don't get
all the benefits of the opt out that
they would have gotten otherwise
yeah once it's the full-blown petri dish
locker room with
stinky smelly sweaty shoulder pads and
helmets and
just everything that goes along with
playing football with a full roster
that is going to be a different
experience and i think we will see
potential changes to the policy as this
goes
i think this idea of taking off the
tracking device at the locker room door
will be something that may be
allowed not necessarily a team goes
rogue here or there
to keep their guys from ending up on the
cobot 19 list
we've seen potential changes to the
confidentiality policy after the matthew
stafford falls positive
so this has to be kind of a living
breathing set of rules because
the more experience that the teams get
the easier it is to refine and
understand and
realize what should or shouldn't be done
which is all the more reason to have
other spots where a limited window opens
to let a guy opt out
i look we've seen eight patriots opt out
five browns opt out no other team had
more than three amazingly the steelers
falcons and chargers had none
but you may have guys who are carrying
around
stress you may have guys who wake up
today and say i blew my chance you may
have guys a week or two from now who say
i really am not comfortable
i i just wonder and this is something
that i hadn't considered until just now
shireen
what happens if a guy just decides
screw it i'm leaving you can call it
retirement you can call it opt out
you can say i'm on the reserve left
squad list you can do whatever you want
i'm not staying here find me take away
bonus money
do whatever you want to do but i refuse
to do this
then the question would become what will
the team
do what will the league do will they
aggressively pursue a guy
who stands up and says i'm sorry
i'm not comfortable here anymore it
would be a horrible pr
mess for a team that tries to extract
every last penny from that guy
in punishment for violating his contract
yeah and i'm not gonna be surprised if
we do see that i
expected more mike i expected closer to
to a hundred
and i expected more big names we had no
quarterbacks on the list they were
mostly
a lineman on the list how many did you
expect to have or did you
not know what to expect when the opt-out
began
well when it began people that i trust
were all poo pooing it and i think that
was the prevalent yeah
belief around the league that it wasn't
going to be many single digits i heard
from several different people and then
we're at single digits on the second day
as of yesterday a lot of guys were
considering it
and a lot of guys were considering it as
a business move
and look i for anyone who was
considering it as a business move i got
no problem with that because you know
what
the league and the teams constantly
squeeze the players
under the guise of business it's going
to happen later this month somebody
making a six million dollar salary is
going to find out in late august that if
he doesn't reduce the salary from 6
million to 2 million
he's getting cut and if he gets cut
there's nobody out there that's going
gonna have the budget
to welcome him in at six million dollars
for this year so
leverage is applied on the players all
the time and
there were players that i know of who
actually felt like
it it would have shown a lack of
integrity
to take advantage of the opt out rule
for business reasons and and i said to
somebody
look i i respect that decision but
reverse the situation if a team has that
kind of leverage
even though it's meant for something
else it's meant for guys who truly are
concerned about playing in a pandemic
they'd take full advantage of that rule
they wouldn't hesitate to take advantage
of that rule so why are players
uh and it's it's on one hand refreshing
but also disappointing because the teams
would never
with very very limited exceptions give a
guy a break under a situation like that
if they have a rule that they can use to
their advantage
to try to save some money save some cap
space squeeze the guy to take less money
do whatever they can do
they'll do it but you know and i don't
want to get too far into the weeds on
this reality
but it became clear to me yesterday
early afternoon
that for players with fully guaranteed
contracts in 2020
whether you have years left on the back
end or whether you're a franchise tag
player like dak prescott
there are solid business reasons or i
guess the proper conjugation now that
the window is closed is there were solid
business reasons
to think about opting out and taking
that fully guaranteed salary for this
year
and bumping it to next year simply
because the way they resolve this
shireen
if half the season goes away if the
season ends at any point after week one
all that money goes you only get paid
for the games you played
and the guarantees are no longer
guaranteed you wait until next year
you and it's kind of like a hedge
against the possibility that
the season isn't going to be completed
but if you have fully guaranteed pay
you're not getting it if the season
isn't completed that's the business
reason
that i thought there would be more
players ultimately by 4 p.m
eastern yesterday who said you know what
i'm i'm i'm making that bet that this
isn't going to work and i'll wait until
next year to get my fully guaranteed
salary
yeah true davious white demarcus
lawrence i mean we heard a lot of big
names that were thinking about doing it
and ultimately decided
to stay around and that is the thing
you're betting now
that that there is going to be a full
season and and i'm like you
i'm not confident as mike tomlin said
yesterday you can't have confidence that
that it's going to be a full and
complete season
uh this year with what we're seeing
especially in baseball
they've had 21 games rescheduled because
of covet outbreaks and
you know we're going to have coveted
outbreaks in the nfl it's going to be a
matter of how many on one particular
team what days of the week it is who's
out
all those sorts of things that they have
enough player to to compete
uh in a game on sunday and that's going
to be the the outcome to determine
whether these games go on the
256 games uh go on this year and finish
and then the post season finishes
so yeah they're taking a gamble now i
think they haven't
decided to stay around and and that it
is going to be a full season and they're
going to play all the games and we have
no assurances that that's going to
happen
and here's the reality the nba the nhl
mls
they are in a full bubble and it's
working right
it's working uh major league baseball
there have been some incidents but the
bottom line is
they don't get in a dog pile every play
they are distant on the field the way
baseball works you've got limited
situations
where you have guys in close proximity
football they're going to be in close
proximity starting
in about 10 days when they do the fully
padded practices
and then when the games start five weeks
from last night texans chiefs
look and i don't want to be morbid here
it's hard
it's hard to have that caveat though
when we got over 160 000 people who have
died as a result of this virus but i was
talking to somebody yesterday who said
let's just do the math here
once we get to early september you're
going to have 170 people
per franchise 170 with the players the
coaches the essential staff the tier one
and tier two personnel
you got 32 teams with that many people
you've got all shapes and sizes you've
got older people who are coaching
you've got younger people who have body
mass index north of 30 who have
comorbidities that could cause problems
when you just look at the sheer numbers
and you stretch it out over a five to
six month period
somebody's gonna die at some point right
they have to be ready
for the reality or at a minimum
very strong possibility that they're not
going to get through a full season
without someone connected to one of
these teams player coach or essential
staff
not just getting coveted 19 not just
developing
symptoms not just being hospitalized or
innovative but ultimately passing away
from this
what happens then shireen we saw
basketball
hockey baseball everything shut down
simply because rudy gobert had a
positive test on march 11.
what happens are they prepared for this
and you know
there's a there's a fear among some
teams
that this is all being set up so the
league office can blame the team
if it happens that well basically hey if
it happens
that means you weren't dotting all the
i's and crossing all the t's under the
protocol
so there's a pressure point there but
regardless of who gets blamed
we all need to accept that this is a
very strong possibility
and we need to be thinking about how
we're going to feel what we're going to
say and what's going to happen
next if and when that occurs over the
course of the next five or six months
yeah there's no question about that mike
it is a danger and we've seen it
baseball at the lower level so some
minor league uh
staffers and and coaches have have died
and
and the game has gone on because it
didn't happen at the major league level
and
as you pointed out corey stringer i was
at cowboys training camp when when corey
stringer died
of heat uh that one year a few years
many years ago now i guess and
and you know things kept going and
players
yeah were more conscious of hydrating
but they they
moved on with the game it's sort of like
nascar when
when they have a death they just keep
going and it's amazing to me but
as you said rudy gobert shut down things
instantly when he tested positive and
who knows where we would be or how long
we would have gone if that hadn't
happened but it seems likely that
we would have had more positive cases
pretty quickly after that but that shut
down everything and
all it's going to take probably is one
death especially a death of a player
that we're going to see this whole i
keep calling it a house of cards because
i do think it's a house of cards we have
going here right now
well and part of the reason is
the way that we have handled the
pandemic as
a society you know people will say well
hey the bundesliga soccer league they
were able to finish
their season premier league finished
their season they're starting up another
one on september 12.
yeah in their countries it's been
contained
in their countries it's been controlled
what's happening here
is we're trying to play football in
these communities where
the virus is just rampant and the
schools are going to open in a lot of
these communities or at least they're
going to try to open them
and and this idea of sending everyone
home
at night even if everyone goes home and
stays home and doesn't go out and do any
of the things that could get them in
trouble with their teams or with the
league
you have other people that you may be
living with who are out about doing
things
and with the prevalence of the virus it
makes it impossible
to keep it away from the players the
coaches the people who go home at night
that's why we're seeing
teams set up these unofficial voluntary
bubbles like the saints in training camp
like the buccaneers are going to have
available getting a hotel
basically booking it for the entire
season and having it available for
anybody who wants to be there
and the more guys who are there shireen
the more pressure there's going to be on
the guys who go home
to not go home and that may be the only
chance look i
there are people in the league who
believe they could have pulled off a
full bubble if they really wanted to do
it if they had started planning it back
in march when they should have
not in july or august when they say oh
crap maybe we should have a full bubble
it's a little late now to do that
but the city by city bubble may be the
only way to pull this
off whether it's voluntary whether at
some point the union agrees to it
but this is something that coaches
players staff need to be thinking of
there may be a full lockdown where
you're in the same city as your family
but you're not going to see them
until the end of the season and that
that's another occasion to have an
opt-out window
even if it's a limited one because there
may be guys then who say sorry i'm just
not going to do this this isn't what i
signed up for but that may be the only
way to pull this off shereen and that
may be the only way to keep
someone from ultimately getting it and
dying
yeah we saw it with andrew whitworth is
the perfect example of that
his nanny went out to lunch with the
family friend ate lunch came home
gave it to everyone in the family
everyone in his family they passed it on
to his in-laws
his father-in-law ended up in the
hospital and nearly died from this
so it shows you how this thing can
spread and kids are going back to school
and they are going to bring it home
and families are going to get it so the
best way to do it obviously is to
sequester the player and
some players are going to do it and some
aren't and it is going to put pressure
on those players
who don't do it because they are going
to be obviously way
way way more subjected to the virus
chances of contracting the virus than
than guys who are staying in a hotel
around the team
yeah i think creativity flexibility
commitment to doing what needs to be
done to protect the players and to get
the games in
everyone now has a clear financial
incentive to get every game
in because the players are only going to
get paid for the games
that are played and if you have a
guaranteed salary it really isn't
guaranteed we've got the stories at pft
check it out and if nothing else at this
point because you can't opt out it
doesn't matter
but the guys with fully guaranteed
salaries have extra incentive
to ensure that their players make good
decisions
and maybe to influence them to volunteer
to stay at the hotel and draw that
bubble around
each team in the hopes of getting all
256 games in
all right the man who quoted the man who
said the only thing we have to fear
is fear itself met with the media
yesterday tom brady had some things to
say you'll hear
about it next here on pro football talk
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports